[Applause]
so
here in this country they're cleaning up
in Florida our friends in Florida from
several States from Hurricane Ian uh but
it's not over thousands of people in
South Florida are still without cocaine
so it is really disrupted
but you know
In This Very troubling decisive world I
thought it was rather encouraging to see
did you see President Biden and Governor
DeSantis of Florida who have nothing in
common and hate each other I'm sure but
they work together and they were cordial
nothing please okay I mean come on give
me something
but I mean it did not last Biden got
back on air force one and it was filled
with Venezuelan migrants
that was a dirty trick
[Applause]
but of course what everyone's talking
about is this picture that emerged of
Governor sent us down there and uh you
know
what
what's with the go-go boots I mean
Hospital
but in Florida I can't even say gay but
I've got to say somewhere in Dallas or
is it cheerleader performing in her
socks I'm just gonna say
all he needs is a wig and he can do drag
queen Story Hour
[Laughter]
oh Republicans they're just like us
uh well our print oh my gosh they do run
some Buttes Herschel Walker have you
seen this down in Georgia you know a
former football player Herschel Walker
who has been running I mean he's a hard
right on abortion no exceptions he is
like rape and nothing no abortion we
criminalized pregnancy in this country
turns out his ex-girlfriend one of his
many ex-grow friends came forward this
week uh with proof that he paid for an
abortion for her
she had a sign check
from him a receipt from the clinic and a
sympathy card
[Laughter]
it's in a jar I mean
and
Herschel it's just not that bright he
signed the card glad to hear about your
loss I mean
[Laughter]
so this this story breaks on Monday the
ex-girlfriend coming forward with all
the evidence and herself it's a flat out
lie then it came forward a few days
later this woman who he said is a liar
had a child with him
and then Maury Povich came out and said
Herschel you are the father